okay Mary here with the news update
according to a new report a game called
Assassin's Creed comet will launch this
year and will let you play as a Templar
just last week Ubisoft confirmed
Assassin's Creed unity for xbox one
playstation 4 NPC another Assassin's
Creed game called Assassin's Creed
comment is reportedly set to launch for
xbox 360 and playstation 3 for the first
time in an assassin's creed game the
protagonist is reported to be a Templar
traditionally the Templars are the main
antagonists of series similar to
assassin's creed 4 black flag this game
will feature a large amount of sailing
sources say the game will be a cross
between Assassin's Creed 3 and the
freedom cry dlc for assassin's creed
black flag players will be able to visit
and sail off the coast of New York said
approximately 40 years after the events
in Black Flag characters such as Haytham
Kenway and Adewale are rumored to appear
we reached out to Ubisoft for comment
but they haven't returned any of my
calls so the story is unverified however
the information about Assassin's Creed
unity was verified after only a week so
we'll be keeping a close eye on this at
gamespot com